سنه ونصف تقريبا على انسحاب القوات
الامريكيه من كابول خرجت واشنطن فاستلم
الطالبان وتربعت الحركه على عرش السلطه في
افغانستان واليوم تقرير حكومي امريكي
تحدثت عن تفاصيله صحيفه وست جورنال كشف عن
ترك واشنطن معدات عسكريه بقيمه سبعه مليار
دولار في افغانستان بعد الانسحاب اضاف
التقرير ان واشنطن جهزت سابقا جيش
افغانستان المنهار باكثر من 18 مليار
دولار وان هناك طائرات وصواريخ ومعدات
اتصال امريكيه وقعت بيد طالبات التقرير
كشف ايضا ان حكومه افغانستان السابقه
تفاجات بانسحاب القوات الامريكيه فيما
اتهم مسؤولون افغان الرئيس بايدن بعدم
الالتزام باتفاق ترامب واشارت الى ان
الكونغرس سيناقش قريبا هذا التقرير
الحكومي الذي تضمن معلومات بان تقييمات
قللت من اهميه سحب المتعاقدين الافغان في
وقت اتهم فيه تحقيق الامريكي اداره بايدن
بالتخلي عن المتعاقدين الافغان